dear fellow Scholars this is two minute
papers with Dr Carol jonai fahir finally
this is my happy episode well of course
I am happy in every episode but this
this is going to be my happy happy
episode if you will why is that well
buckle up because today we are going to
use open ai's Dolly 2 a text to image Ai
and we will see what it is made of can
it create beautiful light transport
effects or not we will see through four
beautiful experiments for instance this
may sound like science fiction but today
we will also see if it can recreate this
scene from a true master of digital 3D
art so what is the slight thing I keep
talking about a light transport
simulation means a computer program that
is able to compute the path of light
rays to create beautiful images like
this and this and this and our key
problem is that initially we only get
noisy images and it can take a long time
for the simulator to eliminate this
noise so can Dolly 2 help with that well
how for instance it can perform a
variant generation where in goes one
image and the AI synthesizes other
similar images this is really cool as it
means that the AI has a good
understanding of what it sees and can
create different variations of it and
wait a minute are you thinking what I am
thinking oh yes experiment number one
denoising let's give this noisy input
image from a light transport simulator
give it to the variant generator and see
if it is able to recreate the essence of
the image but without the noise
let's see well that is super interesting
it did not denoise the image but it did
something else it tried to understand
what the noise is in this context and
found it to be some sort of gold powder
how cool is that based on the insights
gained here let's try again with a
little less noise oh yes this difficult
scene would normally take even up to
days to compute correctly do you see
these light streaks here we would need
to clean those up so variant generation
it's your turn again and look at that
wow we get a noise free image that
captured the essence of our input I
cannot believe it so good interestingly
it did not ignore the last tweaks but it
thought that this is the texture of the
object and synthesized the new ones
accordingly this actually means that
Dolly 2 does what it is supposed to be
doing Faithfully reproducing the scene
and putting a different spin on it so
cool and I think this concept could be
supercharged by generating such a noisy
input quickly then denoising it with one
of those handcrafted techniques for
these images these are typically not
perfect but they may be just good enough
to kick start the variant generator I
would love to see some more detailed
experiments in this direction
now what else can this do well
experiment number two my favorite
caustics oh yes these are beautiful
patterns of reflected light that we see
a lot of in real life and they produce
some of the most beautiful images any
light transport simulation can offer yes
that's right with such a simulation we
can compute this too how cool is that so
now let's ask Dolly 2 to create some of
these for us and the results are truly
Sublime so regular Acoustics check mark
and what about those fun heart-shaped
caustics when we put a ring in the
middle of an open book
my goodness the AI understands that and
it really works loving it however if you
look at those beautiful volumetric
caustics when running variant generation
on that it only kind of works there are
some Rays of Hope here but otherwise I
feel that the AI thinks that this is
some sort of laser experiment instead
and also don't forget about Daniel
baskin's amazing results who created
these drinks but wait we are light
transport researchers here so we don't
look at the drink what do we look at yes
of course the caustics beautiful and if
we are looking at beautiful things time
for experiment number three subsurface
scattering what is that oh boy
subsurface scattering is the beautiful
effect of light penetrating our skin
milk and other materials and bouncing in
inside before coming out again the lack
of this effect is why the skin looks a
little plasticky in older video games
however light transport simulation
researchers took care of that too this
is from our earlier paper with the
Activision Blizzard game development
company this is the same phenomenon a
simulation without subsurface scattering
and this one is with simulating this
effect and in real time beautiful you
can find the link to this paper in the
video description so Canon AI pull this
off today that's impossible right well
it seems so if I plainly ask for
subsurface scattering from Dolly too I
did not get any of that however when
prompting a text to image AI we have to
know not only what we wish to see but
how to get it out of the algorithm so if
we ask for translucent objects with
strong backlighting Bingo Dolly too can
do this too so good loving it and now
hold on to your papers because now is
the time for our final experiment
experiment number four reproducing the
work of a true Master If the previous
experiment was nearly impossible I
really don't know what this is here is a
beautiful little virtual world from
reinante Martinez and it really speaks
for itself now let's put it into the
variant generator and see what Dolly 2
is made of wow look at that these are
incredibly good not as good as the
master himself but I think the first law
of papers should be invoked here wait
what is that the first law of papers
says that research is a process do not
look at where we are look at where we
will be two more papers down the line
and two more papers down the line I have
to say I can imagine that we will get
comparable images I also love how it
thinks that fingerprints are part of the
liquid it is a bit of a limitation but a
really beautiful one what a time to be
alive and we haven't even talked about
indirect illumination dispersion and
many other amazing light transport
effects I really hope we will see some
more experiments perhaps from you fellow
scholars in this direction too by the
way I have a Master Level light
transport simulation course for all of
you free of charge no strings attached
and we write a beautiful little
simulator that can create this image and
more the link is in the video
description and this episode has been
supported by Runway professional and
magical AI video editing for everyone I
often hear you fellow Scholars asking
okay these AI techniques look great but
when do I get to use them and the answer
is right now Runway is an amazing video
editor that can do many of the things
that you see here in this series for
instance it can automatically replace
the background behind the person it can
do in painting for videos amazingly well
and can do even text to image image to
image you name it no wonder it is used
by editors post-production teams and
creators at companies like CBS Google
Vox and many other make sure to go to
runwayml.com papers sign up and try it
for free today and here comes the best
part use the code two minute at checkout
and get 10 off your first month thanks
for watching and for your generous
support and I'll see you next time